what happened with John wick 3 why why
are you hurting me because I was
thinking about you and I'm like so was I
right and there's clearly setting up
this John wick thing well I got going I
got boned into right but it's like now
that had monologues I had a fight
sequence really had a back story and it
got all cut out and I didn't find out
till the screening I think they cut all
of you out or just that all of it I I
think I did one-liners yeah I'll get
your car back to you by the end of year
so I'm just another example of Latin
history being eliminated it's not fair
he eliminated me because my Latin hit
because I'm talking about Latin history
they tell you they're gonna do it no I
just find out at the screening I'm like
what oh man I started throwing chairs
you were right I was upset you should
have been oh yeah and then they're
clearly setting this franchise up to
just go on forever
but they're like he's still gonna need a
mechanic guys he knows how to fight it
not a fix cars right right right but
he'll figure it out it'll probably
they'll cut me out anyway
now he's magical right now he can face
cars all about John wick anymore one
more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM app